hey guys and welcome to another episode
of the outdoor boys YouTube channel
today we're experiencing NASCAR that's
right we're going to our very first
NASCAR race in Richmond Virginia you
ready guys we're here and we gotta go
get our credentials I'm getting press
credentials or something like that so I
can film there and get a little behind
the scene tour and all that stuff let me
go to the credentials office get our
special passes alright so we got our
cold passes that led us back into the
garages and pits there's a cold past for
Tommy so we've got our stadium seats and
they're cold passes but you let us do
the behind-the-scenes tours and I think
it's gonna work out I just left my keys
to sitting in the ignition here in the
car open cool now we need to go find
where our parking spot is so all right
guys we made it we got parked and we got
a pretty good parking spot so we're
gonna go in and see if we can turn the
garage and stuff like that any rate I'm
excited okay this place is insane
there's just parking lots upon parking
lots and there's certain sections that
are for RVs and there's people throwing
tailgate parties and stuff all over the
place never seen so many American flags
is the first time we're all in hold on
time
[Music]
holy mackerel this place is huge
good bye is a native Baba yeah that's
right
[Music]
that's a Hummer gonna go take a look at
it
the thing is that a pretty awesome there
yeah Tommy that's where the guys with
the machine guns sit up there come on
boys how about alright so the passes we
got are supposed to let us into the
garage and the pit area until the race
gets going so I'm getting excited we
even check this out
all right boys come on all right
apparently we're taking a shuttle ride
to the infield so we're gonna see what
well it took a couple transfers through
a few shuttles but I think we're here
where the garage and pimp entrance it
doesn't be excited to see some race cars
I don't care if you're into racing or
not this is cool
yes
[Music]
they're cool nobody's dinkles
and Tommy don't touch anything yeah
those are race cars these guys got a lot
of tires up
Bass Pro Shop Cabela's yes that's a jam
right there
just take one
yeah yeah isn't that cool
getting ready for the race
Fahmy tired Nate did you having fun
buddy that's a lot of tires right there
all right guys let's go over and see the
pits this is cool
all right there's pit road
well guys this is the pitlane where they
do the maintenance on the cars during
the race it looks like they'll let you
actually go out on a little portion of
the racetrack up there so I want to go
check that out
[Music]
the racetrack man this is where the
magic happens there's a steep Bank on
this sucker too
[Music]
you tell me then you want tell me why
you want to get that one
I think Nathan's really hungry he came
running over here like a gazelle hoid
this one all right I've had like three
different people tell me I look like
Kyle Busch he's a lucky man though if he
looks at anything like
anytime you want cherries yeah there we
go your gummy frog well we got about 30
minutes before the race starts and sun's
starting to set it's cooling off a
little bit I think you're ready to do
this all right there's the garage area
where we went and saw the cars right in
there and over there is the pit where we
were walking tell me are you excited
Nathan are you excited well this is our
very very first NASCAR race so we don't
really know what to expect but we're
excited and it's beautiful beautiful
weather so this would be awesome
they're doing a little intro of the
drivers right down there got a little
smoke machine and stuff going on you'll
see the drivers coming out of there
[Music]
a lot of sporting events do the national
anthem but here they do a prayer the
national anthem a couple other patriotic
songs jet flyover skydivers in fireworks
so they definitely take it to their
backs here at the eschar
[Music]
Wow that is awesome oh my like this I
really had no exposure to NASCAR before
coming to this race and it was just blew
my mind first off the race cars are just
bone-jarring loud I mean it is
incredible to be in their presence I
thought the kids would be bothered by it
but Tommy absolutely loved it he ate
where it he hated where his ear
protection though it was really good I
bought it the other thing that blows you
away is how fast these cars are and
you're sitting way up in the stadium
seats or you're kind of videotape it it
doesn't do it justice these cars are
moving close to 200 miles per hour and
you could go down right up against the
fence and watch them and you're standing
about eight feet away from 40-something
cars going 200 miles per hour you can
smell them and feel them and hear them
it's it's absolutely incredible it's
really cool too because anybody can come
down from the stadiums and walk there
along the fence and get right up close
to the action about halfway through the
event I took the boys to the end of the
straightaway across with them gets
and it was just happening
we're sitting there and bits of rubber
from the cars tires are peeling off and
flying through the air and hitting you
in the face
like that's bits of car tire
you just don't appreciate how fast and
powerful these cars are it's a real
experience it's like standing next to a
jet as it goes off an aircraft carrier
it's incredible one of the things that
surprised me about NASCAR is how
fast-paced it is it's not like baseball
or football when there's all these
breaks it's three hours of almost
constant action the other thing is
there's like 43 drivers and so you're
not just having two teams fighting each
other it's a battle royale and 43
individuals duking it out for each
position so lots of action is going on
at the same time and it's just an
experience like no other sporting event
now Tommy got really into it he liked
the M&M car and that was driven by Kyle
Busch about halfway through the race
Kyle Busch got out and just duped it out
for first and
[Music]
Tommy did you have a good time
yeah Kyle Busch the M&M car took first
place
Tommy's very happy well guys we better
get these boys to bed it's way past
their bedtime
hopefully enjoyed this video if you want
to see more great videos from the
outdoor boys YouTube channel don't
forget to nail
[Music]